he's deemed Blandino Fox Sports NFL
rules analyst in the former NFL VP of
officiating Dean thanks for joining us
let me start with the Lions game and
explain and you were right on it by the
way you said I think it's gonna be
reversed and I think they're gonna have
a ten-second run off with eight seconds
to go the game was over so thanks for
joining us explain when that rule was
Rica was created with the ten second
runoff yeah so the ten second one up has
been in the rules since the 50s and and
the theory was at the time the rules
committee looked at okay what would be
what would be a standard for a team to
be able to get lined up legally for the
next snap and it's it's not perfect
because we know there are different
situations where it may take less time
or it may take more time but they came
up with a standard for ten seconds and
then in in 2009 there was a play it was
a it was a st. Dolphins game and it was
at the end of the half where the Saints
had the football the ruling on the field
was a touchdown the Saints were out of
timeouts there were five seconds on the
clock and the call was reversed to down
short of the goal line and the Saints
got another snap and the committee
looked at that and they say really had
the call been correct on the field the
clock would have continued to run they
they never would have gotten another
snap off so they instituted the
10-second run off to say in replay if
the ruling on the field stops the clock
and then you reverse it to a running
clock inside of a minute at the time now
it's two minutes it's going to be a
10-second one off and that and that's
the rule that was applied yesterday in
that situation and with eight seconds to
go basically Detroit's out of timeouts
the game is over do you like that call
you know I hate a game I hate for him to
end like that it just felt it's the
right rule it's the right call and and I
think most of the time it is an
equitable result I just I don't like
that a game ends like that because you
have then you have the what-ifs well you
know it was only a 2 or 3 yard play
Detroit probably can get lined up the
problem is is you have to have a
standard let's say it was a 30 yard play
are they going to get lined up in eight
seconds and it's impossible to say we're
going to take each situation on its own
you
to have a standard the standard is 10
seconds that's been the standard for a
long time and in a situation yesterday
just it was to the detriment of Detroit
let me ask you about the unsportsmanlike
conduct penalty with Vaughn Miller and
Tyshawn Taylor I think initially the
announcers thought that it was on the
hit and then it wasn't on the hit it was
he he was goofing with Tyrod Taylor
gonna help him up and then pulled his
hand away both laughed about it or both
pointed at each other and then that
resulted in a penalty should it have
resulted in a penalty you know and just
what what I saw just visually I didn't
think it was a foul now now I don't know
you don't know what was said obviously I
know Vaughn came back and he said him
and Tyrod her friends and they came out
the same year and they were joking
around you would hope that the official
would be in the vicinity would be able
to recognize that it's tough for the
officials to know hey these two guys are
friends they're joking around and and
two other guys may not be joking around
I just think the visual of the pulling
the hand away was was to me not enough
for a 15-yard penalty unless there was
something more sinister that was said
which I don't believe was the case but
but again just what I saw visually that
didn't look like a foul to me the
difference between taunting and
celebrating the fine line are how how
are these officials taught that that's
taunting and that's just celebrating
yeah I think so what's what's being
taught is if it's directed at an
opponent its taunting if it's just done
with a teammate it's done to the to the
home crowd that it's not directed where
you're facing an opponent you're
standing over an opponent then then it's
not a phallus if you're not doing it
direct at an opponent and it is a fine
line I think what we're seeing you know
as we open up the celebrations and we
allow for more of this expression I
think in some instances we've seen
players score touchdowns and start to
celebrate and the and the defender
getting annoyed and coming over and
knocking the football away so it is a
fine line officials are really looking
for did they do that at the opponent or
are they just kind of doing that with
with their teammates
and and there's there's subjective
there's judgement there and there's some
discretion on the official that they're
gonna have to they're gonna have to
enforce those those fouls Odell Beckham
lifting his leg as if he were a dog
urinating is he is he taunting players
or is it just inappropriate celebration
yeah that was inappropriate celebration
any any time and I think there are a
couple of things that that are gonna
draw the foul that are considered in
general offensive and anything to do
with I'd say bodily function for lack of
a better term but that's going to be
considered offensive and you know you go
back to the Randy Moss with the with the
the mimicking of pulling down his pants
and mooning the crowd those types of
things are going to be considered
offensive and you won't have to direct
that at an opponent for it to be a foul
it still drives me crazy this complete
the process you had that yesterday in
the Giants game yeah I mean yeah Dean if
you catch the ball it shouldn't be that
if if sterling Shepherd catches the ball
both feet inbounds goes out of bounds
takes a cup you know slides a little bit
and then the ball comes out it feels
like the NFL is just holding on for dear
life for this Calvin Johnson play
complete the process which was erroneous
in the first place and it's 10 years ago
and here we are still doing that silly
thing why I even and I don't and you're
perfectly justified to feel that way I
really I don't think the Lea cuz I've
been a part of those discussions I don't
think they're holding on to Calvin
Johnson I do think that the rule for the
most part for for the overwhelming
majority of the plays is a good rule
because you can officiate it
consistently in real time and the rules
are written for the officials to
officiate in real time and replay then
starts to starts to distort you know you
can slow things down and you can make
things look different than than what
they actually and how it actually
occurred I think you're always going to
have plays like Shepherds play there was
another one
Sanders yesterday that you sacrifice
those plays for the greater good and and
and the overwhelming majority of these
plays we're receivers go to the ground
and the ball pops loose the rules a good
rule but you're gonna sacrifice these
handful of plays that look like catches
feel like catches but again for the
consistency of the officiating of the
rule I think I think it is a good rule
but again I tend to agree that there are
going to be those plays that it does
feel nitpicky and but it but for the
overwhelming majority I think the rule
works but if the ground can't cause a
fumble why do I care what happens when
you catch the ball in the endzone both
feet inbounds and you go out of bounds
sure it's the ground can't cause a
fumble but it can cause an incomplete
pass come on that's crazy we could go on
and on about this and crazy we're
talking to Dean Blandino Fox NFL and
college rules analyst is targeting
working in college football that penalty
I think it is working I think you you
see it every every week where players
are adjusting I do think that the the we
have to be careful about just the the
number of targeting calls it feels like
and not that it just feels like they're
up they're up this year I believe going
into last week there were there were 31
more fouls called an FBS so it's it's a
point of emphasis it's safety so it's it
so it's a good rule but I think we just
have to be careful about just overdoing
it and we did see some calls this week
in in the studio where it felt like bad
that's not the intent of the rule and
thankfully some of those were overturned
in replay but you do see the rule
working it is you know losing losing a
player for the game you know getting
getting kicked out of the game is the
ultimate deterrent and I think it is
working you're seeing players kind of
lower their target and keeping the head
out of it I think I think the NCAA is
doing a good job of just making sure the
officials understand you know what is
and what isn't targeting and making sure
that that they don't they don't go
overboard with it and I know that we're
trying to change how kids tackle and
you're hopeful that they take that into
the NFL and I I don't know if we'll get
to
where we have targeting in the NFL you
know kid when do you have these kids
change how they tackle learn to tackle
differently you know it starts when
they're younger but can you absolutely
change them when they get there already
in college can you change them and
certainly when it gets to the end do you
see targeting in the NFL I guess is what
I'm getting it well I think the NFL
ruled the defenseless player rule covers
the same the same things that the
targeting rule covers yeah so it's no
less or more restrictive I think the
only difference is you don't have the
automatic ejection so it's it's more or
less the same rule I don't think the the
automatic ejection is necessarily the
way to go you can find players you can
spend after the fact and you have the
ability then to take in all of the
mitigating factors and and and look at
it in a controlled environment and not
make a hasty decision I do agree I think
tackling starts at a young age and and I
just don't know you know I've talked to
so many coaches and and they just they
don't have enough time with the players
to actually teach tackling and by the
time they get to major college or NFL
it's probably too late it really has to
start at the high school in the junior
levels and and I think that's happening
more and more I think you have more
programs USA Football heads up football
where coaches are getting certified and
they're teaching better tackling
techniques and hopefully that generation
of kids will grow up and and will be you
know it'll it'll make the game safer in
the future so that that's the hope Dean
great stuff thank you for joining us we
appreciate it
you got it Dan dean Blandino Fox Sports
NFL rules analyst former head of
officials with the NFL the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience